profiling is the lazy man's national
security policy I mean it's it's the
easiest low-hanging fruit it's red meat
to the masses but I want to be clear
here profiling isn't only wrong from the
perspective of you know sort of who we
are as Americans it's actually bad
security policy we live in a time in
which people are becoming radicalized
but let me just put this in perspective
there are six million Muslims in America
there is maybe a handful of arrests and
essentially five successful attacks
right and most of them were stabbing and
then we had San Bernardino so let's put
this in perspective those are great
numbers
we are not Europe Europe has a
generational problem and that is because
they had immigrants or people who did
not fit the European profile who are
growing up as Europeans traveling to
Syria to arm and train themselves and
returning back home that is an epidemic
that is a systemic problem of which a
society Europe is going to have to
confront that in a real way it's law
enforcement is not going to cure this
problem we don't have that problem and
the reason why we don't have that
problem isn't because we're surveying
Muslim communities or we're keeping them
out it is because we as a country
through fits and starts and we haven't
been perfect we as a country have been
able to assimilate and acclimate and in
invest in and welcome the other right
not always perfect I'm willing to admit
that but whether it's Hispanic or Muslim
or Arab or Irish over time those
communities view America as their own
they don't travel to Syria to come back
and harm Americans and we must commit to
that integration to that sense that we
don't view these populations as the
other so things like profiling or
following mosques or keeping certain
religions out or you know wiretapping
Imams I mean all the craziness that
you're hearing right now
I promise you will make us less safe
over time and so it's it's not just an
argument about the left and you know the
heartstrings and feeling progressive
versus the right and Pro security it is
if in the course of America's history
the you know besides our oceans which
have helped a lot that the one attribute
of our policies that has made a safer
and more secure is our ability to absorb
and welcome and integrate new
communities and we we have to remain
committed to that people know that their
risk of them dying from terrorism is
like point oooo 1% you know divided by
10 like I mean we know the risk is very
very small but people also do feel like
the world is kind of on fire those
aren't inconsistent to me right I mean
you can you can still feel very nervous
about the world out there and recognize
that the risk to your own family are
pretty minimal and I think that
President Obama sort of focuses on the
first right and I think in some ways he
needs to tell people I get it though I
get those fears and you know here's what
we're doing and here's what you can do
and these other guys to be honest these
other guys and all they're tough talk
that won't work you know and and and
sort of accept our own irrationality I
don't know if that's fair to say but I
know then them I mean everyone knows
that the numbers are incredibly low but
if it's you know if it's your kid that's
the point
oh-o-oh 1% you know that is an
existential threat you know the phone
calls I get in the last couple of months
from Paris attacks on are real I mean
they're the real concerns of people who
care everything for the their children
in their lives or their spouse or their
extended family and these are real phone
calls of real concern and I I worry that
Democrats in particular worry
President Obama tends to think of this
stuff rather rationally isn't quite
getting the emotions right and the
emotions aren't being you know
cultivated by cable news or Don
Trump only I mean I think that there are
real concerns for people and their
families right now and sometimes I wish
you know President Obama would just say
like I get it I have two daughters I get
it you know I get it you're not
irrational but let me tell you what
we're doing and what you can do to
address it because I do think that if we
view those who are nervous about the
world right now you know whether it's
Zika or terrorism or hurricane seasons
coming up that that if we don't channel
that those concerns someone like Donald
Trump walks right into the vacuum and I
think that's what's happened a little
bit